لقد تجاوز مستوى التجسس الصيني
أي شيء رأيناه في الحرب الباردة
من قبل وتحتاج الولايات المتحدة إلى التفكير في
طريقة جيدة للتعامل مع ذلك
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى] [
تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أنا متأكد من مايكروسوفت  لقد وصل إلى
مستويات هائلة من الجهد
لإخراجهم، لذلك ربما تم إصلاح كل شيء، إنه
مثل عملية سطو، نعم [
موسيقى]
ولذا إذا كنت تفكر في الأمر على أنه تحطيم
والاستيلاء على الصينيين، فقد حصلوا على الرموز المميزة،
وتمكنوا من الحصول على المفاتيح  في الشبكة،
أه تم نقل كمية هائلة من
البيانات الشخصية، أفترض أنني أعني أن هذا
ما يريدون فعله.
الأشخاص الأجانب الذين يعتقدون أننا يمكن أن نكون
أصدقاء مع الصين يحتاجون حقًا إلى أخذ
نفس عميق، على الرغم من أن الصينيين
هم الأكثر
وكالة تجسس عدوانية في العالم
مثل